all right what are you doing here
Charlie uh you know I I I think there's
been a murder
ER
well you know you know and not a murder
but an attempted murder right so I I
think someone trying to kill that little
[__] dog
a dog
you do know my brother just died right
oh
and I'm very sorry uh I I'm just I'm
trying to figure out what happened so
someone beat it with a log over by your
brother's trailer which I I mean I get
it that thing can be a real thing but
then they moved it I mean that's weird
right what do you mean they moved it
well because of the pecan the P what the
pecan wood
I could hear when I tasted
there were traces of pecan wood in the
dogwoods and that means the murder
weapon came from okay when did you
become CSI look it's just a dead dog in
Texas that's it
close proximity to each other my
brother's death is not mysterious
tragic
oh
yeah but now that we're talking it
through uh
I think maybe the dog saw something
related to your brother's death like
what like I don't know what
malfeasance malfeasance or something
that someone didn't want it to see and
they felt that the dog had to be
silenced I mean you do know dogs can't
talk right well nobody's saying dogs can
talk so what are you saying Charlie
oh
he said he'd tell me later
the last time George and I talked he
said tell me something later
he believed it
and that means you know he thought he'd
be alive at the end of the night
we're all taking this really hard
Charlie
do you know I would give all of this up
to have my brother back [__]
laughs
sorry
[Music]
you know what I think
I think
you need to get the [__] out of town
and don't show your face around here
again
because in Texas
no matter if you came out of other we do
not smile kindly on trespasses
is that purely decorative
not entirely no
yes
[Music]
oh yeah I know but he basically said
he'd shoot me if I go back there
you might be right but we don't have any
proof
I don't know I just say we move on first
start you know put all this behind us
foreign
I don't even like you
[Music]
fine listen you gotta stay here remember
you're a wanted [__]
right I'll put on the sicko I don't know
about you but what I do in the bathroom
definitely ain't gender neutral
[Music]
thank you